hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
november 7th
2021 what's going on how are you
how's it going in your world man
you having a good time what the [ __ ] is
wrong with these headphones oh i see
what i did wrong
i see what i did i see what i did how
about now oh there it is oh my god
that's amazing
didn't have the whole [ __ ] thing
plugged in jesus christ is that an omen
omen omen
um i usually i would stop at this point
because it's i'm only like a [ __ ]
40 seconds into this thing but you know
something
i got [ __ ] to do man
right um i am currently in san jose
cruise san jose california
and i still have one more show to do
here i had a great time up here in san
jose
um i stayed out in their area there that
it's sort of like they just decided to
build their own rodeo drive
it's really bizarre because like across
the street diagonally there's like one
of the most [ __ ] up cvs's i've ever
been in and just i'm not [ __ ] on cvs
i've never
really been in a [ __ ] up cvs they're
all kind of the same this one
you know is like a barn find where it's
just original paint you know all
original flo floor tiles
original
[ __ ] that they sent to the store i mean
the [ __ ] shells were bare i mean
there was there was uh
didn't feel like a cvs you know what i
mean
you know when you're sort of going into
the rip-off chain of the chain you want
to go to that's what it felt like didn't
feel like a rite aid or a dwayne reed
didn't feel like a mom-and-pop one it
just whatever [ __ ] cvs bought
i don't think that they remodeled
uh this one yet but then like right
around the corner they have like this
you know this whole little [ __ ] area
you know those areas where people have a
certain [ __ ]
you know
they're just bored and they need to buy
the nicest version of dumb [ __ ]
you know i mean it's like you can go to
[ __ ] cvs and buy some nail clippers
for like i don't i mean what what do
they cost i have no [ __ ] idea
and i feel like george bush
senior when he didn't know how much a
dozen eggs cost i just don't know
because i don't pay attention like i
don't get like i just walk up
and the lady just goes
and i go okay can i just stick my card
in
i can't
the amount of times that i'm just not
listening
um whatever say like nail clippers we'll
say they're what they're like i don't
know a couple of bucks three bucks
you know this is the kind of area where
they would actually have fifty dollar
nail clippers or some dumb [ __ ] like
that they have a pot sorry which was
actually nice
i will give them that it's nice it's
just that with my mask on and their mask
on and the sound of the refrigerator we
couldn't hear each other and i was
ordering
you know i was like can i get some
oatmeal he's like he's like what are
those
guys
and then i finally just you know
she said we don't have oatmeal and then
i panicked
because there was people behind me and i
just said all right let me just get the
quiche
she's like vegetable or bacon and cheese
i said vegetable
uh i'm sorry i said bacon and cheese and
she goes oh okay and then she brought me
vegetable and my dumbass i ate half the
quiche before i was like there's no
[ __ ] bacon in here
this is called killing a day
um and then there was like two or three
ferraris that just kept circling the
block which after a while i just became
convinced that
this whole little rodeo area they rent
them
and their job is to drive around the
block
so people think that they're in this i
don't know what
this oasis of uh
illuminati people
um
those super cars are [ __ ] hilarious
though
park them in front of the hotel and all
these people gather around they take
pictures of them and [ __ ]
uh don't know you got to have a certain
personality to drive that car huh just
who the [ __ ] wants everybody looking at
him all the time
listen to me
i only do it for an hour a night and
then i just i slip off into the darkness
i go right out the back of the theater
like a [ __ ] rat and i get in the car
and i leave
and that's it and that's what the [ __ ]
i'm doing tonight
that is what i'm doing tonight
oh freckles i'm getting right in the car
and i'm [ __ ] driving home i was gonna
fly back but i miss my wife and kids too
much
um
it'd be kind of fun if i
get home in the middle of night and my
daughter wakes up because she didn't
think i was coming home wake up and make
her pancakes or something like that like
[ __ ] joe pescian casino
um his character i should say um so i'm
going to be doing that tonight we drove
over from reno
and there's no way to be in reno and not
think about lake tahoe and there's no
way
to think about lake tahoe and not think
about the godfather part two
you know
and thinking about fredo going out there
to go fish and getting [ __ ] shot in
the head
and michael corey alone
hanging his head down classic
classic goddamn scene
but um
i was psyched i was able to take uh dean
delray was over here and i've been
telling you about this place for a long
time bizarre guitar and gun shop out
there in reno and uh
i took him over there
they got all these amazing guns and then
they down downstairs at the uh
the [ __ ] music store they got this
unbelievable collection of guitars and
all this [ __ ] and dean was just losing
his mind
he was going like dude look at that
marshall stack
the all red are you kidding me
that this marshall stacked from the 80s
like literally
you could play the [ __ ] worcester
centrum of the providence providence
civic center sorry those are the ones
that i grew up in or the boston garden
or madison square garden with this
[ __ ] stack they had two giant ones
and they were red
and dean had never seen him in red i
guess i never saw him in red either
i thought eddie van halen's were like
that matched his guitar i have no idea
but he saw him and he [ __ ] freaked
out
um
and then we just had nothing but great
shows nothing but great shows the whole
week two friday two saturday and now i
got one tonight i'm gonna go up there i
love one show after doing two shows a
night for a couple of nights and you
have one show it's like having a half
day of school remember that is anything
better than the half day of [ __ ]
school
it was so stupid that we all showed up
but it was just great to be there and be
excited with every other kid we got a
half day
we gotta we can get the we're getting
the [ __ ] out of here at noon
is that what time it was you went to
school for nine to three when you were a
little kid you'd have a half a day
because there was a teacher's meeting
and even the teachers were excited
because they weren't going
they weren't going to the meeting
you know
i'm sure there was the one that did
or the two that did and then the next
day in the teacher's lounge
you know
gave them dirty looks
didn't see you at the meeting you know
here you are always complaining that
there's not enough number two pencils in
manila uh [ __ ]
legal pads you know where were you at
the meeting
you just come in here to smoke your
cigarettes is that what it is
um
so anyway i'm in um
san jose and
i was going over to the cvs
because you forget forever like running
out of [ __ ] toothpaste or vitamins or
[ __ ] or me because i'm going to a
football game i went to the 49ers
cardinals game
and um
you know i had to get earplugs because
the [ __ ] game the goddamn scoreboards
are so [ __ ] loud now i feel like i'm
at a concert and my ears ring loud
enough
thank you very much right so
we go over there and he somehow brings
up
the winchester mystery house
because you haven't been to that dude
it's red
i'm like no i haven't what is it he
starts describing it and my brain went
back 40 years ago and holy [ __ ] i
remember hearing about that house
anyways
this is house out here
this woman sarah winchester who was
married to william work
w-i-r-t william wert
winchester
of win the winchester uh
rifle fame
the rifle that you know how the west was
won that was the gun that was [ __ ]
used
so they were living in connecticut you
know making all this [ __ ] money and
then the guy dies
and i don't know i i sort of breezed
over it the big [ __ ] thing was
she bought this house right
and she was convinced that it was
haunted
by all the people that had been killed
by the the rifle that her husband had
invented and that they made all the
money off of
so for some reason she she went to some
psychic or some [ __ ] and the guy told
her they were in connecticut saying you
need to move out west buy a house and
keep [ __ ] building
on it to keep these [ __ ] ghosts at
bay and she did and she built like
stairway
staircases that led to nowhere
i had no idea the house was that big it
was like
160 [ __ ] rooms
uh we tried to go in we just didn't have
time because we were going to the game
and i remember seeing a story on this
house on one of those pm magazines
you know
they get like a
a white guy and a white woman you know
the guy would wear like a sweater
she had like [ __ ] pleated pants the
[ __ ] early 80s right
and uh you know she'd have like the lady
diana haircut
and then he'd have sort of the [ __ ]
grant good eve
from eight is enough haircut they all
had they all looked the [ __ ] same
right and uh they did a thing on this
and they made it seem like she was just
talking about you know
ranchers shooting [ __ ] horse
wrestlers and [ __ ] you know okay
corral and billy the kid jesse james
[ __ ]
and uh you know
since being out here and i just started
i don't know i was looking up the 49ers
and i was like what exactly what was the
gold rush and all of that type of [ __ ]
and just reading up on it i'm like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
wow
yeah so i came up if i talked about this
like uh there was like a genocide out
here oh i talked did talk about this of
indians right
people wanted it you know
went into pan for gold
and it was really inconvenient to these
people who came out here when they were
staking their claim that there was
already other people here
and they would kill them and enslave
them and take their kids away from them
just [ __ ]
horrific [ __ ]
and um
it's just funny today i'm like going to
a football game
and you know the cheerleaders are called
you know keep it going for the gold rush
dancers
and then they got this
dumb mascot you know doing like the
49ers
dressed like a miner
i'm like jesus christ
like how soon before [ __ ] woke
culture comes for that one [ __ ] nfl
man
they're gonna have to change after
goddamn thing cardinals somehow they'll
relate that to the catholic church
they'd be like are you advocating the
rape of children all right [ __ ] it we're
calling the sparrows
um
anyway so i was standing outside that
house and i was thinking like wait a
minute so was she not really we're
necessarily talking about you know
white people shooting other white people
you know
sort of the sheriff going after the uh
you know the guy in the black cat or
whatever
was she actually
thinking about what was going on
you know out west
or i guessed everywhere and um you know
it's always interesting you know when
you read about [ __ ] like that
because they kind of make it seem like
because it was happening nobody paid
attention or nobody cared
so anyway so i was thinking okay
i thought they lived out here and the
[ __ ] was going on and she felt so guilty
she built the house but she was actually
living in connecticut
and this [ __ ]
car salesman psychic told her oh you got
to do is uh move out west
get a house
just keep building so anyway if you're
in san jose
the the um the winchester mystery house
you should definitely check it out it
ain't cheap it's 41 bucks
you know per adult but if you see how
big the [ __ ] place is i'm sure the
the upkeep uh just vacuuming in it alone
has got to be crazy right
um and it's right next to their little
phony uh
the soto sopa [ __ ] uh rodeo drive and
i know i use that
reference all the time now and i don't
give a [ __ ] because i want everybody to
see that
south park
episode on gentrification
telling everyone about that so anyway
let's get to the football today
i went to um
levi's stadium
levi jeans basically stadium and uh it
was kind of funny they were going are
you going to be in the 501 uh luxury box
i was up there with al madrigal i was
[ __ ] i'm like no i'm going to be on
the button fly terrace
right next to the acid wash men's room
right
but um i got to tell you something man i
loved the [ __ ] stadium when i pulled
up to it at first i was like this looks
like a [ __ ] old roller coaster
like this looks like an old stadium in a
way inside it doesn't look like that but
on the outside the way they built it
this looks like an old stadium
and uh my buddy was telling me he said
no man they built this stadium
to uh
to be like efficient and make sure you
know that they can pay the [ __ ] thing
off and he said that that stadium down
there that the chargers and the rams
are in is like a [ __ ] you know 60
billion vanity project and they're never
gonna make money off of it which i
thought was interesting
it was like well why the [ __ ] would they
build something knowing they weren't
gonna make money off of it
it's like oh that's right because it's
all our money being loaned out and then
these rich [ __ ] getting [ __ ]
interest off of it
and getting greased and all of that was
really interesting
um
the confusing thing about the stadium is
like i was just so psyched it was like a
perfect day for football it was really
sunny and everything but that [ __ ]
stadium must get cold as [ __ ] i was
thinking like oh this is great we're
inland we're towards san jose the
weather is perfect it's beautiful we
were just standing out on the terrace
and it wasn't even like a uh like a
you know little gust or anything that it
was just a steady
stream of air
like you felt like you were right on the
water
and uh
these people out here they're so used to
it they're like the amount of people i
saw at the game and like shorts and a
tank top and they were sitting in the
shade on like uh
our the side that we were sitting on you
know
sitting on the uh the home side
and uh
you know dean was making fun of me
because i had my sweatshirt and my
leather jacket it's just like dude i'm
not catching a [ __ ] cold
i always overdress if i'm going to go to
a game because he can always take layers
off i'm not going to be the guy showing
up
you know dressed like [ __ ] richard
simmons and all of a sudden he gets cold
out and i'm sitting there my candy
striped shorts and i got nothing to do
there
right
so um speaking of richard simmons man
that guy like [ __ ]
he crushed it
he made all his money and when he was
done he just left
he just [ __ ]
left and he did it in such a [ __ ] way
people like worried like something was
happening with them that somebody was
like holding them hostage and
controlling his money he was just like
nah man i'm good
i'm good i'm done no more sweating to
the oldies i saved
you know nobody really he really showed
you the whole time his career was going
you could see how much money he was
saving because you know he wore those
shorts for like [ __ ] 40 years
i mean they literally stopped making
those shorts
the candy striped shorts and like i'm
trying to think
i mean they uh you know
sort of skanky chicks when i was in
junior high in high school wore those
things
you know
early 80s or something
so he kept the same wardrobe it was
brilliant
i think michael jackson was doing the
same thing like he just kept those
[ __ ] loafers and socks forever
because he blew his money on that you
know [ __ ] monkeys and [ __ ]
iron lungs to sleep in or whatever the
hell he did i'm sorry people my brain is
all over the place right now let's get
back to the game
all right
i gotta do a [ __ ] show after this too
jesus
oh jesus
um
the 49ers uh stadium yeah so i really
liked it and uh
their fans are [ __ ] hardcore
um
it was funny dean was going like uh yeah
this is going to be the wine and cheese
crowd
you know as opposed to raider fans where
you know there are a bunch of animals or
whatever and i went to the game i was
like this is not a wine and cheese
crowd everybody here looks like they can
beat the [ __ ] out of me
but they were super passionate and i'm
going to tell you something man not only
great fans in a great stadium which i
said i [ __ ] loved it you know the
parking sucks but there is a train that
comes right up and you can also uber to
the game
you know
the reality is no stadium has good
parking
they have enough parking
it's not good
you know
unless you leave at half time then it's
f and it's fine
um
but anyway uh
i would say
in the nfl the san francisco 49ers when
they wear the gold pants
in the oakland raiders when they have
the white with the silver number those
are the two
best uniforms
arguably in sports
they're just
iconic
they haven't changed them 49ers [ __ ]
with it a little bit you know and they
had those stupid white pants that really
just
ruined the [ __ ] uniform
uh thank god they went back to the gold
pants but um
i still got i still got to give the edge
to the raiders so as far as the logo i
mean come on
you can't [ __ ] with that logo
that was literally that like
like the raiders should have sued
star wars like darth vader
you know that was totally their vibe
or whatever i feel like darth vader is
like just a derivative of the [ __ ]
raiders logo i don't know
maybe i'm nuts who the [ __ ] knows um
i gotta a workout in all three days
oh [ __ ] uh billy two-step here
finally getting this [ __ ] covered
weight off
two pounds a week something that an old
man like me can handle
um throwing the weights around i'm
getting my late 80s [ __ ] body bag
pencil thin [ __ ] legs with a little
v-shape up top that's how you did it
you know
everybody in the 80s that worked out
looked like that [ __ ] guy in the the
incredibles
[Laughter]
everybody just had these massive [ __ ]
upper bodies
and then just walk around with your
little [ __ ]
your bird legs
um
i don't know i'm trying with my legs i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm i i never miss a
leg day right that's not that's not true
i miss leg day but i don't always miss
leg day but when i do no i don't miss
leg day but i just can't they don't get
any bigger
it just it is what it is and this is how
you end up doing hgh
or if you're a woman how you end up
getting [ __ ]
you know your ass fat
extracted
you know like you're basting a turkey
and [ __ ] shot into your lips
at some point you just gotta [ __ ]
accept like hey you know i just don't i
didn't get those jeans
you know what i mean
i mean
[ __ ] is what it is like why would you
know you're gonna sit there and uh
become obese with goddamn fat is just
beyond me not fat with [ __ ] uh muscle
because i was thinking of that too right
like you [ __ ]
even when you're putting on muscle
that's you're still adding mass to your
body
which means your body then has to grow
capillaries which means your heart has
to pump
blood through those capillaries right so
you're still making it work harder
you know that's a that's a probably a
stupid question but to me i think it's
interesting
let me see this is too much muscle
is unhealthy as too much fat
is too much well it's probably not good
let's just say it's too much muscle
unhealthy
it's got to be you're obese with muscle
while muscle is never unhealthy and you
can't have too much of it
it's fine to strive for more reasonable
goals
all right that's not answering i mean
let's see here aka h
gh
the health risks of human growth hormone
all right can you imagine if i took that
[ __ ] right and i got jacked but my head
got even bigger
my
god
i only could get work in horror movies
how long do i got to be in the makeup
chair ah bill we were kind of thinking
you you could just come down to set
uh you might think ted cassidy the actor
well i don't want to start naming names
here
oh
who played
the butler lurch on the addams family
was
tall
but richard keel also known as the steel
toothed jaws and james bond franchise
was even taller
what the [ __ ] does this have to do with
human growth homer
[Music]
oh because both of those actors
had acro
megaly
the pituitary gland in their brain
releases too much human growth hormone
often this is caused by a benign tumor
of the pituitary gland
bone growth from this hormone gave these
performers extraordinary height as well
as enlarged hands feet and facial
features so this is what people take i
wonder if they started like working out
back then if they just become like these
adonises
but complications from acromegaly
acromegaly
included arthritis sleep apnea diabetes
high blood pressure heart disease and
often premature
death both ted cassidy and andre renee
rosimov died at age 46 from cardiac
complications related to that yeah
because your heart doesn't grow right
your heart's still the same size
everybody gets the same size heart human
growth hormone has a i have no idea what
i'm talking about by the way human
growth hormone has a vital role in our
growth and health but abuse can cause
permanent health issues and shorten your
lifespan sometimes too much of a good
thing can be bad for you
what is human growth hormone i jesus
christ can you just answer the [ __ ]
question human growth hormone is a
peptide oh good
so that's what a peptide is
like the proteins that make our hair
nails muscles and skin
a peptide is a chain of amino acids okay
good they explained it to me there's no
reason to lose your temper bill peptides
are shorter than than proteins which
means they degrade and digest more
quickly human growth hormone doesn't
promote growth directly instead it
encourages the liver to release
insulin-like growth factor
which thickens and elongates bones
wait so you can get taller doing this
[ __ ]
all right you know something i'm gonna
walk away from that
like that's one of those things where
i'm just so [ __ ] dumb all i'm gonna
walk away from that is just more
questions well that's the fun part of
learning
no it isn't
not if you don't want to learn and you
you want it to end
the amount of [ __ ] in my life that i
have done
that i've just been counting down i just
want it to end
when does it end
like what percentage of your life i
think that is like
you know it's it's a good benchmark of
whether or not you like your life
or you you had a good life and you
enjoyed it
by how much time you spent staring at a
clock
i know my entire school [ __ ]
scholastic career i just [ __ ]
just kept looking at how the [ __ ] is
only 10 20.
oh my god i hate this class
what do you mean i got to do a paper i
don't do a [ __ ] paper
you know
amount of times i sat staring at a
[ __ ] watch hoping our flight was
going to be over
the amount of time
i've run my yap on a podcast and
completely forgot what the [ __ ] my point
was and what i was talking about i mean
it's just
it's incredible
it just goes on and on and on um i think
my point is
that i'm trying to jam a [ __ ] podcast
in
before driving home tonight
even after daylight savings not daylight
savings the regular time we went back to
regular time
which i got to tell you i [ __ ] slept
great last night
you know getting that extra
that little bit of extra in there was
[ __ ] amazing and then i went down to
the gym which was right next door to my
room i threw the weights around
this younger kid comes in right
and he comes over all they had was one
bench and there was nobody in there
you know the typical hotel chimp you
know a couple of ellipticals couple of
treadmills couple of bump you know
dumbbells and then just the whole
[ __ ] universal station right so i'm
over in the corner minding my own
business and this [ __ ] kid comes in
and you know
he opens up the door to get some air in
there
you know that person they come in there
and it's just like you know they'll
change the tv they just start doing [ __ ]
like they're making it their space like
oh [ __ ] you know
i thought i was gym guy i thought you
know i evidently i just came to the gym
this is gym guy look at him he's
rearranging [ __ ] furniture he's
opening the [ __ ] window he's doing
all of this [ __ ] right
so meeting him like all right why is
this [ __ ] hotel guest acting like he
[ __ ] like this is his gym
so i'm already starting to like look at
him in a certain way you know so then he
[ __ ]
comes over to where i'm at i'm thinking
all right this is weird there's only one
bench over here and i'm you know work
out little [ __ ] thing here and i'm
not done with it so i don't know what
this guy's doing
and he just grabs like all these heavy
dumbbells and walks to the other side of
the gym and he keeps [ __ ] dropping
him on the floor even though there's a
[ __ ] sign that says don't drop him on
the floor
right
and i'm like all right i'm starting to
get this guy
i'm starting to get this guy this guy
has to come in and he has to dominate
the space
you know
he's coming in and the first statement
he makes is that the hotel isn't running
their gym right and now he was like on
like the uh the bar he was like the bar
rescue guy of like the gym so he comes
in he [ __ ]
you know he's letting the air in
now he's grabbing these things the sign
says don't drop the weights he's
dropping the weights anyway
you know because he's above the [ __ ]
rules
right
but i'm not gonna lie to you man like i
kept watching him when he was working
out because he was doing all those
modern [ __ ] things i still do the
exact same workout i did
when steve winwood was winning grammys
you know
give me a higher love i still i still
i wanna be
you sledgehammer peter
gabriel you know i still do the exact
same [ __ ]
the same [ __ ] i've done some [ __ ] with
bands you know rehabbing my [ __ ]
shoulders and stuff
but i still basically i do the exact
when it comes to weights i do the same
thing and this dude
he was doing these things like
genuflecting while holding a dumbbell
one dumbbell over his head
with one arm right and then he would
walk towards me
as i'm on the bench you know like he's
gonna [ __ ] t-bone the bench
then right when he couldn't take another
lunge he would then back up
and then he'd come back at me again
right with the other arm in the air with
the same dumbbell right coming at me
like a [ __ ] meerkat you know lunging
trying to look bigger like some cobra
that went down his [ __ ] hole right
so uh
down his hole mean down into his [ __ ]
you know house there with the little
little meerkats who are not [ __ ] up
his ass in case people got confused with
my varmint
reference are meerkats considered
varmints
all right these are the questions i have
i got to look this [ __ ] up
um but anyway his [ __ ] working out
made me feel like
is he like laughing at me looking at me
watching
like i'm over here
i'm gonna [ __ ] bench and then do some
curls and then do some tries and then do
the shoulders then
[ __ ] sit up stand go back to the room
order [ __ ] donuts oh yeah
um
hang on a second here
uh
but then i looked at him and i'm like
he's really not in good shape you know
he's got all the she's got all the gear
you know he's over here opening windows
he's doing these 20 21 exercises but
maybe i'm catching him at the beginning
beginning maybe he's turning his life
around
are mere
cats
varmints
why do meerkats stand up
wait i gotta find out what
i didn't know if i spelt it right what
is a
varmint
a var oh it's m-i-n-t of varmint a
troublesome and mischievous person
especially a child
wait a second
one classified is vermin vermin
and unprotected by game law
oh you can just [ __ ]
he can just shoot a [ __ ] raccoon
right
synonyms for varmint
bastard beast bleeder
blighter
boar bounder bugger
buzzard cad chuff churro clown
[ __ ] clown
um
rats mice
and other varmints
the sheriff in the movie gets resent on
the dirty varmint who killed his brother
oh i get it
um
all right there we go let's uh
all right let's do the ad reads here
let's do the ad reads uh indochino
uh you know there's never been a better
time to upgrade your look
indochino's black friday event
has their lowest prices of the year on
suits shirts outerwear and more plus
you'll save even more by using the code
bur
indochino offers completely custom
fitted suits shirts casual wear and more
at surprisingly affordable prices get a
wardrobe personalized to your lifestyle
and taste without spending a fortune
measure yourself on the website
in 10 minutes then wear your suit out of
the box in three to four weeks every
piece has made your exact measurements
and you can customize every detail
choose everything about your suit
including the fabric the lapels monogram
and statement linings you can create a
suit that fits you and your style
perfectly the best part indochino suits
start at just 2.99 and starts and shirts
started from 45 bucks with all
customizations included get away from
the video
calls and back and get away from the
video calls and get back in and back
into looking and feeling amazing
oh i see get away from your zoom calls
all right indochino's black friday event
runs from november 8th to november 29th
save more
save even more and get 50 off any
purchase at 3.99 or more by using the
promo code bur at indochino.com
that's 50 off a purchase of 399 or more
at i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code burr
[ __ ] throat is so dry man
the goddamn altitude up here um oh look
who it is everybody
do me undies
me undies
why are you building that house to do do
do me undies me undies because of my
murdering spouse
all the indians just about got murdered
and so did a bunch of i don't know other
[ __ ] people with my husband's [ __ ]
guns
so i kept building a house that's really
[ __ ] sad
but at least i did and [ __ ] myself all
right
me undies so the holidays are almost
upon us and it's time to really lean in
we're talking hugs
we're talking seek we're talking secret
family recipes we're talking about
seeing the looks on your loved ones
faces as they all unwrap their matching
pj sets at the same time this year
meundies wants to help you bring comfort
home for the holidays this is your sign
to surround your family and friends with
the comfort while you're at it why not
get a little something something for
yourself too with new classic plaid and
holiday sweater prints me undies is
turning up the comfort this holiday
season their undies loungewear and
sleepwear are made out of soft
breathable stretchy fabrics that are
ideal for getting cozy by the fire with
hot cups of cocoa
jesus christ none of that was your idea
was it
um honey you want to make coco and sit
by the fire in pajamas
make the whole family smile
uh with matching pj sets or spoil your
partner with plush robes and slippers
whatever you decide everyone will be
rolling into the new year comfier than
before available sizes in extra small
through 4xl me undies has a little
something something for everyone on your
list looking for more inspiration check
out your their holiday gift guides for
all things cozy and comfy the undies has
a great offer for my listeners for
anytime first purchasers you get 15 off
and free shipping right to your door
your day of your days your days of
fighting for your life in the mall
parking lot are over
uh to get 15 off
your first order free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
that's
meundies.com oh this is a really
interesting one everybody loves this
thing solo stove
you know there's nothing quite like the
feeling of gathering
around a warm fire on a cool fall
evening and a smokeless fire pit from
solo stove makes
your outdoor moments even more memorable
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax and actually enjoy the fire
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit google that solo stove
they're really cool slick looking
enjoy the warm ambiance the mesmerizing
flames and all the opportunities to
create more good moments and lasting
memories make the time with your friends
and family richer with a solo stove fire
pit solar stove fire pits are
brilliantly engineers and beautifully
crafted made from premium grade 304
stainless steel and a patented 360
degree airflow system that maximizes the
efficiency while minimizing the smoke
that's the only thing sucks about
sitting around the fires when the wind
you know starts blowing all that [ __ ] in
your face uh easy to light with a few
bits of starter your fire is blazing in
minutes perfectly portable take solo
stove with you on camping trips and more
i'll take it to tailgating
give a [ __ ]
what are you cold yes i am and i'm man
enough to admit it get the perfect fire
pit for these far these those fall
nights
uh make your backyard a destination with
a spectacular fire pit from solo stove
shop the fall event now and get an extra
10 off when you you use promo code bird
checkout they're so confident you'll
love it they'll offer a lifetime
warranty and a 30-day free return policy
just go to solostove.com and remember
you get ten dollars off when you use the
promo code bur
all right
um okay native american preference all
right we got people here
chiming it chiming in chiming in um
all right
native american preference okay here we
are we got the reeds here everybody
we're doing the reads native american
preference hey billy little boy blue
i'm commenting on the last podcast about
native americans versus indians
yeah i was saying every uh
native american ever met
they haven't met a lot they all say you
know i'd rather be just called an indian
as an actual card-carrying
quote native american i think indian is
still the preferable term in fact it's
in our tribal name
i'm probably going to say this one the
seneca nation of indians
in an informal survey of my res still
pretty much prefers the indian term
maybe because native american sounds
like a pc term or just because
the american term is still an example of
colonial terminology applied to natives
in fact native
is probably preferred over native
american american i got the hiccups
sorry
so there you go
this person goes on to say
it still doesn't help everyone thinks
we're of mexican descent and speak
spanish to us whenever they can i live
in boston too i got numerous examples oh
jesus
anyway have a good one and go [ __ ]
yourself
um yeah so there you go all right
application
yeah that's the amazing thing about like
all of this stuff like i don't think
like these nicer names obviously you
can't say a racial slur i'm not saying
to say that but these just continuing to
improve on the name
but never really trying to undo some of
the wrongs
or whatever i mean i don't know how you
would do that but like
um
i do think that you know they need to
like
you know
with history you can't just have the
people that won
you know
turn in the people they murdered into
mascots and team names
or name streets and golf courses after
them as a tribute is kind of you know
i don't think that's enough
um
it's weird the whole [ __ ] thing is
just weird how it's all teams so you
don't like my italian friends get so
[ __ ] mad that they're losing columbus
day slowly but surely
and they're all like [ __ ] that he never
did that [ __ ] that's [ __ ] he never
it's like dude
who the [ __ ] knows what happened
nobody's saying you did it
you know
every race of people has their
sweethearts and they also have their
jeffrey dahmer's we just need to just
[ __ ] you know
take everything out of the cabinet and
align it up the way it should be and we
can all [ __ ] agree on it
i don't know i just don't understand
like uh
at this point
what the problem is okay native american
preference uh okay i just read that one
uh appalachian
appalachian writing in about the
ignorant south all right so here was my
thing all this [ __ ] came about when i
was watching the world series
and um
you know i'm trying to root for the
braves because they've been there for so
many times
and uh every five seconds they're more
on fan base is [ __ ] doing the
tomahawk chop
so i don't know i was just thinking
about it and i just came up with this
theory that you know maybe if northern
whites treated southern whites better
after the civil war or somehow got over
the fact that they tried to secede from
the union you know the bad blood
ended
and they didn't you know try to fiscally
fiscally [ __ ] them over
and have prejudices against the accent
and all that type of [ __ ] and showed
them some empathy and late night talk
show hosts didn't constantly do jokes
about southerners you know [ __ ] their
own sisters and hillbilly [ __ ]
maybe they would be more empathetic
and when people said hey you know that
tomahawk chop thing ah you know you
might want to think about that they'd be
like all right you know i'm open to that
um it's just an idea i had right i don't
read
so this person is writing in about the
ignorance appellation writing so he
lives somewhere in the appalachian
mountains dear billy turkey titties
turkey tits would have been better i
still like turkey titties but turkey
tits gets it's you get the alliteration
almost three times because the e ruins
the t
titties turkey tits
all right there turkey tits i mean
that's [ __ ] great that's right out of
jerky boys
um this this letter is already a winner
turkey tits
i heard your podcast where you briefly
mentioned your theory that if
northerners were more compassionate to
southerners then maybe they wouldn't fly
such blatantly racist flags or be more
considerate of other cultures etc yeah
basically paraphrase what i just said
i've lived in west virginia since i was
around five years old because i choose
to further my education because i chose
to jesus christ too stupid to read his
[ __ ]
sentence in my language about education
i still [ __ ] it up and because i chose
to further my education
because i formed my own opinion based on
facts and refused to let social media
like facebook brainwash me
you sound like you're fighting it sir
fight the good fight
and
uh and a smaller
and i a smaller percentage of folks my
age aren't hateful and ignorant like the
people before us
all right something happened when you
rewrote that sentence anyway he goes it
doesn't mean we're not piss-poor though
uh what so many people fail to
understand is that places like west
virginia are essentially third world
countries inside of the united states
west virginia
specifically
was stripped of its resources by coal
companies and while reaping the benefits
of coal paid miners next to nothing and
fought
tooth and nail
with the military at their side to stop
them from unionizing google the battle
of blair mountain see this is more
[ __ ] that should be in the history books
now here it is this is uh
this is white people [ __ ] with the
poorer white people
what a surprise
um
the battle of blair mountain b-l-a-i-r
look that up uh if you want uh poor
funding across the board from
infrastructure to education is a main
factor in what makes people ignorant and
hateful here
yeah
yeah i mean
listen to me every once in a while you
know broken clocks right twice a day is
what they say i think i stumbled onto
something a huge portion of people here
don't even have access to the internet
uh with a piece of [ __ ] like joe manchin
mankind in office to represent this
place you know that nothing is being
done to help poor people the [ __ ] just
shut down the billionaire tax even
though zero billionaires live in west
virginia our governor big jim justice is
also a [ __ ] idiot
please tell me that's his name
um
here is
here he is reacting to covert numbers a
few months ago
i don't want to watch another guy in
office just [ __ ] ignoring doctors uh
the people that have brains and
intuition to make this state better end
up leaving because of all these factors
above there's practically zero
opportunity here and i'll tell you
something i've been to virginia it is a
[ __ ] gorgeous state
absolutely one of the most beautiful
parts of this country the fact that
you know and there's no news even about
this [ __ ] what's going on down there
uh i could go on much longer much longer
rant about all of this [ __ ] but i'll
end with this west virginia is a
beautiful state see filled with
untouched wilderness and huge potential
to be a state like colorado in the
future if we did things like legalize
marijuana and put money into the public
education and infrastructure yeah in
some way there would be a tipping point
and they would just start building
[ __ ] glass towers and all of that
[ __ ] so
i don't know
they just [ __ ] make everything all
corporate um but i i hear what you say i
wish it was a way to just help out your
state
you know
without having all the corporations then
descending down there because people
have money
uh the reason that it's destitute is
because of the rich taking advantage of
our resources and our people huge fan of
everything you've done from your stand
up to your character on the mandalorian
i'm a little behind on efforts for
family but i plan to binge it all once
the last season drops i'd love to see
you do a show in charleston i'd love to
do one there
um
thank you uh he says i know both bert
and tom are going to be here soon
uh well those two guys are going there
jesus christ i don't need to go there
those guys are going to destroy thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself so there you go
there you go i like hearing come on man
everybody write in i'll be like the
[ __ ]
the michael moore
of of podcasting except what i won't do
is act like canada is this super happy
[ __ ] place where you don't have to
lock your doors
you know
and nobody does anything bad to anybody
and there's never any riots
and they love when a person
you know who isn't white plays hockey
they always have wonderful experiences
in the minors
um why southerners do weird stuff here's
another guy right now
hey billiam of the crimson sack
i like that that's [ __ ]
you know if i knew what my family crust
was i might have that written in latin
underneath it
um been listening to your podcast for a
few years now first time writing in love
your stand up in your podcast keep up
the great work i was listening to your
podcast
from last week uh november 1st 2021
um and heard you wondering about why
people from the south do stuff like fly
rebel flags and other stuff that seems
stupid and or outdated
um
yeah i'm gonna stop short of saying
stupid because i don't want to be like
[ __ ] you know
i remember how bad i did in high school
so i would just say
uh you know the lack of empathy
dare i say the pride and kind of going
out of your way you know
to hurt other people
is is what i find confusing
you know but then again i have a
crushing need to be liked so you know
anyway i'm from north carolina go tar
heels and i see things like the rebel
flag pretty regularly the attitude
generally doesn't seem to be one of
hayford towards a certain people or
anything but usually one of regional
pride
parentheses love must spread
i do think that there is an element of
spite involved in a we're still here
kind of way but it seems more defiant
than anything
as for the attitudes of people from
other parts of the country towards us
southerners meaning northern whites
people on the coasts
uh it's rarely ever a positive one no i
used to do a bit in my act
you know
something you're going to touch upon
here i can see in the next sentence here
i'll read your [ __ ] first and i'll do my
bit i have a degree in electrical
engineering and have kept my accent
since moving out of the south but i get
funny looks from time to time or even
straight up told my accent sounds
uneducated
yeah i think how [ __ ] up that is
you know mark twain was a southerner
right there's a bunch of super smart
[ __ ] southerners but i'm too stupid
to remember all of them
but um i used to bit my act saying like
if if albert einstein had a southern
accent
you know no one would have listened to
him he would have been up there you know
and i pointed i can't remember i did
this on my first half hour be pointing
at the board going hey
equals mc squared
people shut up you [ __ ] more come on
man i'm serious this [ __ ] [ __ ] works
um something like that but there's true
there's a prejudice against your accent
sometimes it's a bit more subtle where
people will say something like wow i
didn't expect you to know so much as if
i didn't spend eight [ __ ] years in
college yeah
yeah that's what i loved about the late
great vic henley
vic henley kept his uh
his accent
and was a super smart guy
with you know being a super smart guy
had really smart material and i used to
love
watching him killing in new york city
um
and he never really addressed at least
all the years i watched him he never
said like you know i don't really
remember he just sort of talked about
life and would crush um anyway now
granted we're easy to make jokes out of
and we're one of the few groups of
people left
that it's considered safe to make fun of
or mock just for the circumstances of
their birth so i can't fault people for
hanging on to that but it doesn't but it
does foster a bit of resentment
especially when you see people act like
there's
not other parts of the country just as
ignorant if not more so than the south
well hey i've been to them all and i can
i can definitely tell you
that the you know the east coast
meathead myself being one could give you
southerners a run for their money
um
yeah
i just went to a football game today i
saw a lot of great people saw a lot of
animals i mean you go to his sporting
events the [ __ ] animals come out
um yeah so
yeah there's one for you i think just in
general if people
like we're just going in this really bad
direction
of
um
egos and name-calling and if people
people could just sort of [ __ ] relax
a little bit
and just step back and kind of because
we could go back to maybe a little
common decency but then you know
that doesn't even make sense because
there was you know air quote common
decency
decades ago i feel
but like a lot of other [ __ ] was worse
so i don't know i know what the solution
is
you know when when's jesus going to be
done with that nap i mean what exactly
does how bad does it have to get before
he comes back and he's like oh jesus
you have to come back down there you
know [ __ ] settle things down is that
what he's gonna do he's like settle
things down
you know
like shit's getting out of control in
this squared circle he's going to come
running out of the locker room like a
[ __ ] wrestler is that what's going to
happen
all right question
hey billy bucktooth
uh my name is carson
i'm a 19 year old from iowa i've been
listening to your podcast for a little
over three months now and i'm a big fan
i listen to your shitty podcasts
on my long walks to school and from
long walks to and from school and let me
tell you the stupid-ass looks i get
uh from laughing at your jokes makes the
walk even better oh that's great i got
to get out there man i want to say i
have a gig somewhere out there i've got
one question you
for you that i always try to ask people
that look like they've made some
mistakes
what's one thing slash piece of advice
you wish you could have heard
around my age
only one
said i'm fresh out of high school here
she says fresh out of high school
now a sophomore in college i want to
hear from the man himself what he wishes
he did or didn't do should i do that
bowl of meth
or keep on rolling on with college and
join the math team or some [ __ ] like
that best of luck to you and keep
rocking all love from iowa
keep rocking man um [ __ ] the one piece
of advice dude
it's too big
it's too big uh
you know what
i love when i i get like a variety pack
from a cigar company
so why don't i do that i'll give you a
variety pack of [ __ ] that i wish
um
[Music]
don't be so hard on yourself
um
walk up to her and say hello
who gives a [ __ ] then you don't have to
carry the [ __ ] what if for the rest
of your life
um don't get a credit card
um
uh [ __ ] i don't know what else what else
learn about money
it's too big dude you're making my head
explode i'm just i'm [ __ ] running in
50 directions i [ __ ] everything up
i [ __ ] everything up
um
i don't know i would say if you want to
run for public office or something like
that
you know
that's what i would do i would treat my
life in a lot of ways like i was running
for public office so i would really be
careful
about anything that you you sent or
whatever on the internet or joked around
with through text messages and [ __ ]
because they seem to
go back eight nine ten [ __ ] years and
just trying to destroy your [ __ ]
career
this is what you said and you guys by
the time you know you're of age to go
run for some big office a big 30 years
ago you said this and it's just like i'm
not the same person i was [ __ ] 30
days ago
so um
i don't know dude
just try to be a good person
life isn't as tough as you think it's
going to be
i would just you know really [ __ ]
enjoy all aspects of life you know
something getting old too is not a bad
thing
and unfortunately you're actually gonna
realize it's a blessing someday if
you're uh unlucky
you know to lose some friends along the
way
and uh because that's a real mind [ __ ]
you know
some of the friends that i lost
at such young ages and i met them when
they were super young and if you told me
when i met them that they were already
halfway through their life i mean i
don't even know how i would even handle
that so
um all right i think that's enough vague
[ __ ] that i could tell you i i think i
would
i would
if you ask me something a little more
specific maybe my [ __ ] add wouldn't
be bouncing all around but like really
be careful with money
okay
marry somebody that you love that you're
crazy about and that like it's easy
they're easy to hang out with they
should feel like a friend um
yeah that's oh god i know so open all of
this stuff if somebody's treating you
like if it's work
get out of the relationship if it's just
a friend or like a girlfriend boyfriend
whatever your thing is there just get
out of it
just get out of it just if you have to
just sit there and think to yourself
well maybe if i acted this way would
things be better
it that that is
right there it's over
the second you're thinking like i need i
mean unless they're calling you out on
like you know like my wife going like
you gotta
you know quit yelling at [ __ ]
appliances in the kitchen you mean you
know certain [ __ ] you have to [ __ ]
listen to but other stuff you can just
you know
if i'm like okay maybe if i pretend to
like this kind of music then will they
not be upset with me or will they like
me yeah [ __ ] all of that
[ __ ] all of that and pay attention you
know as you move through life
if you start doing well and you know
people you thought your friends started
acting weird yeah you let them go too
that's how that works
and then one day you know you're sitting
alone in a [ __ ] hotel room in san
jose with nobody to call no i'm kidding
i had to make a joke at the end all
right um
let's plow ahead here
that was the question and then i got one
last thing here and then i gotta go do
my show all right
book recommendation
dear billy book smart
i know
you're a busy man
but i really think you should download
an audio book called tribe
by
sebastian younger spelled j-u-n-g-e-r
he's a writer who served in vietnam and
has spent his life learning about
cultures from around the world he
details what it
it is that makes humans feel fulfilled
oh [ __ ]
maybe the person who
asked that other question may read this
book instead of listening to my dumb ass
uh interesting things like the
phenomenons of communities go through
hard times
and now in the present looking back on
those times as the best times of their
lives
okay interest i'm sorry i didn't read
that right interesting things like the
phenomenon of communities going through
hard times and now in the present
looking back on those times as the best
times of their life
lots of it comes from how they connected
and felt part of a group it goes way
beyond this
he reads the book himself which makes it
more compelling
it helps me clarify certain thoughts i
was having about where to live what size
city or town please please download this
and let me know what you think
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself i might
check that out
if i have some [ __ ] time to listen to
somebody read me a book
does he start with once upon a time i
don't want to fall asleep
[Laughter]
anyway um
let's see how long did i do here did i
do enough time did i do my time yeah
hour and six minutes here
a couple things i got to cut out
uh tighten the [ __ ] up here
like this right here um all right that's
it everybody thank you for listening to
the podcast
um
go [ __ ] yourselves
you know and uh except if you're down
south
you know have a wonderful afternoon and
i'll check in on you
on thursday
you